das ist ein desaster es wird mit uns im
moment umgegangen die mit dem letzten
dreck man wird diskriminiert man wacht
morgens auf und wies in der bild
irgendwie das einsparen sagt mallorca
wird das neue ich will oder ich habe
hier auch nochmal eine headline von
kretschmann epidemien entstehen auf
großveranstaltungen und das hat mich
jetzt einfach mal bewogen zu sagen bis
hierhin und nicht weiter und es muss
irgendwas passieren die
großveranstaltung da reden wir ja jetzt
erst mal gar nicht drüber aber es wird
ja so getan als wenn alles
selbstverständlich ist das alles
abgesagt wird und dass das auch
entschädigungslos abgesagt wird und um
mich geht es dabei ja gar nicht so weil
ich bin ja musikproduzent aber ich sehe
es halt an den künstlern die fristen
treffen mittlerweile den kit von den
fenstern und die veranstalter drohen
reihenweise pleite zu gehen
und ja das ist der punkt
man muss man halt mal anfangen so
aussagen wie mallorca wird das zweite
spiel
man kann das überhaupt nicht vergleichen
muss man das einfach mal klarstellen und
finde ich sollte es auch mal vorangehen
dass man sich eben auch mal um diese
berufssparte nämlich die der
veranstalter der künstler unsere weiter
kümmert umsatz von 130 milliarden euro
ist das nämlich keine kleine sparte ist
die ökonomische seite aber ist ja es
muss einfach irgendwas passieren und die
wir werden ja es wird ja über uns hinweg
gebügelt wir kriegen verbot zur
großveranstaltung in derselben woche wo
ich bei facebook bilder sehe von
demonstrationen die sicherlich einen
guten hintergrund haben das will ich ja
gar nicht infrage stellen aber es ist
noch mehr als despektierlich wie hier
mit der branche also der musikbranche
insbesondere umgegangen wird
naja also die meisten ich kann mallorca
bereich sagen da haben eben nicht alle
vorgesorgt gerade in newcomer die
grabmale produktion bezahlen können wir
haben eben nicht 30 40.000 mal im jahr
zu überbrücken oder wir reden ja
vielleicht mittlerweile schon von
anderer teil und es findet ja nicht
statt es gibt
so gut wie keine entschädigungen die gvl
hat 250 euro gezahlt das reicht einfach
nicht
und es wird einfach seitens der politik
da völlig darüber hinweggegangen ja also
ich habe noch nicht einmal gehört wir
müssen jetzt den wir müssen uns mit dem
thema befassen und wir müssen auch mal
vielleicht mal experten fragen die sich
damit auskennen weil dieses thema wird
ignoriert dass das ist einfach den
leuten geht es schlecht und die haben
auch vor allen dingen angst künstler
sind ja sowieso sehr sensibel und sind
auch das letzte glied in der kette so
das ist darf man ja nicht nur das ist
die autoindustrie ist ja wichtiger wer
alles wichtiger als künstler im moment
ich weiß noch nicht ob das so lustig ist
wenn irgendwann mal keine helene fischer
schon mehr gibt oder kein ballermann
mehr gibt das nicht ob das ein schönes
leben ist jetzt ist aber das problem wir
jetzt haben wir schon eine karnevals
session 2001 zur disposition
also er hat ja keine planungssicherheit
die künstler nicht wann sie wieder
auftreten können die veranstalter wissen
gar nicht was sie ob sie 2021 was machen
können
es hängen alle völlig in der luft und
ich glaube dieses in der luft hängt das
produziert bei den leuten oder bei den
künstler natürlich auch angst angst ist
ja sowieso das riesenproblem gerade weil
ganz deutschland hat scheinbar angst
wenn ich bei facebook lesen ist ließ nur
noch angst ich hab angst ich habe angst
denn damit kann man einfach keine
schlacht gewinnen aber es fehlt einfach
einfach eine marschroute wo man das test
machen kann das ist ja super das ist
gutscheine gibt nur was den festivals
wieder statt
ja wann treten künstler wieder auf wann
können künstler mit was rechnen
das ist doch die frage also ich weiß
sogar dass schon auftritte in 21 seitens
des carnevals abgesagt worden sind und
deswegen kann ich die panik der künstler
absolut verstehen ja das ist ja und das
ist auch diese angst wieder das blöde
wort angst aber dass diese angst die ich
habe dass man von dieser welle seitens
der politik auch gar nicht mehr runter
kommt und was mich und das muss ich
einfach nochmal sagen da absolut ankotzt
ist diese selbstverständlichkeit mit der
die politik das entscheidet ohne
erklärung ohne wen an die hand zu nehmen
ohne fahrplan
das wird entschieden und jetzt müssen
damit klarkommen wie gesagt ich weiß
dass veranstalter auch große
veranstalter teilweise veranstaltung in
frage stellen mitte 2000 21 es liegt
nämlich auch daran dass da sponsoren zu
erforderlich sind
dass man so etwas planen muss das
künstler natürlich auch verfügbar sein
müssen und also ich glaube dass das also
wäre schön wenn das dann am 31.10
gegessen ist aber das erwarte ich gar
nicht ich glaube man muss einfach auch
mit der politik konzepte entwickeln um
mal zu gucken wie man das ernst so was
vernünftig machen kann weil es nicht
falsch verstehen ich bin jetzt keiner
der sagt wir machen jetzt
stadionkonzerte ja als wenn gar nichts
mehr das ist der falsche weg
aber man muss doch mal mit leuten die
sich damit ausgenommen markus krampe ist
oder ob ich es bin eher mal einen dialog
treten und mal gucken wie man so was auf
die reihe bekommen kann für so viele
künstler